All right, Clinton, last try. Ma'am,
you're back. Can you hear me? Can you
hear me? There you go. There you go.
Okay. Sorry about that. Um, I'm on the
Muslim side for sure. And let me just
say it's kind of offensive to throw the
Muslims in with the Morbids, but uh I I
have a Jewish You said it's offensive.
It is offensive. You know that. Why is
it offensive? Well, I'll put it this
way. There's an old Jewish joke. Why did
God create Christians? So, so Jews So,
so Christians or excuse me, why did God
create Mormons? so that Christians will
know how Jews feel. And uh I I really do
I really do hear that from my Jewish
brothers and sisters. Because does the
same joke go for Christians? Like
there's a joke that says, "Hey, why did
God create Jew uh Muslims?" And then the
answer goes so that so that they know so
that the Christians know how the Jews
feel or something like that. Oh, okay.
Well, we can keep this joke going, I
guess, right? Um but but Paul is the
Joseph uh Smith of the first century. Um
there's nothing about Paul's uh jumping
into the Christian movement that we
should believe. Why should we believe
that Paul saw an apparition of Jesus on
the road to Damascus? Right. So So you
say that you should not, you know, you
shouldn't believe like you have no
reason to believe Paul's, you know,
claim of revelation on his way to
Damascus. Um, do you have reason to
believe Muhammad's so-called revelation
in the cave of Hera? Well, yeah. Well,
Muhammad's revelation doesn't um
contradict everything we know about
history. Whereas whereas what is Let's
talk about Hold on a second. Hold on.
What about the cave of Hera? What about
the cave of Hera matches what we know
about history? Let's say even
specifically
um the history of how prophets receive
revelation. How does the cave of Hera
match the historical fact of how
prophets usually received revelation? I
don't know. I mean, Moses went upon
Mount Si and received a revelation from
God. Did he get choked out? Did he get
choked out? Well, I mean, Jacob is
wrestling with an angel. Yeah. But did
Jacob get choked out? Did he think it
was a demon that he was wrestling with?
Did he feel suicidal afterwards? I don't
I don't know if he felt No, no, Jacob
did not feel suicidal. So, so we never,
so historically, we never see prophets
feel suicidal or oppressed by the
messenger that God sends or even God
himself. Yet, we see Muhammad in this
cave supposedly gets this revelation and
feels oppressed, comes out with his neck
twitching in fear, tell his wife to say,
"Lover me, cover me." And um wants to
commit suicide after. Are you saying
depressed or oppressed? Oppressed. Both
actually. if you're thinking about Okay.
But yeah, in in the Hebrew Bible, you
see all the time that when prophets
encounter uh the angel of the Lord that
they are in gruesome fear of the angel
of the Lord. And what happens what
happens when they see him and they're
startled? What what does the how does
the angel of the Lord respond to their
fear? Does he continue to oppress them
and increase their fear or does he
comfort them and tell them fear not?
Well, it depends on which verse. I mean
there the angel of the Lord interacts
with any verse where the angel of the
Lord increased their fear where he
oppressed I don't know well I don't know
if he increases necessarily their fear
but I don't know if he necessarily
always relieves it there's there's never
there's never a time where the angel of
the Lord appears um and he oppresses the
person he comes to never there's never a
time where he oppresses them but we have
Muhammad in the cave of era who gets
oppressed by this spirit entity so the
question is does that match the history
of the prophets? What do you mean by
oppressed? Because so not being in so
being in fear. Is that what you mean by
oppressed? No, not simply being in fear
because you could be in you can be in
fear but be but then be comforted or be
reassured but be in fear have that fear
amplified by physical attack and a
physical attack, physical
oppression, right? um and and continuous
uh continuous physical oppression and
you know like for what we have with
Muhammad's example we have him at the
cave a spirit comes to him tells him to
read he can't read why is the spirit
telling him to read if he can't read and
then when he can't read the spirit then
presses on him until he can't breathe
anymore and does this to him multiple
times the same process so so similarly
we do actually have an impression. I'm
glad that you you brought that out
because when Paul and again, I don't
believe this story, but when Paul
allegedly through Luke Acts encounters
the risen Jesus, what happens? He hears
a loud sound. He's made to go blind.
He's in fear of who's talking to him.
And apparently, he's still
blind. Where does it say he's in fear of
who's talking to him? Where does it say
he's when the It says a loud voice like
thunder. I mean, that sounds pretty.
Yeah, but she just read that in there.
Okay. So, maybe he's happy that a loud
voice like thunder blind. But just
Clinton, can we let's notice how I'm I'm
being honest with your That's
oppressive. Being blinded is oppressive.
Clinton. Clinton, come on, man. I'm
being honest with your sources. Be
honest with mine. Does it say that Paul
was in fear of the person he was
speaking to? Okay. I get the sense that
he was in fear, but those words are not
there. All right. So, it doesn't say
that. So, that's you reading that into
the text. Here's my second question.
Here's my second question. Does does the
person who visits Paul announce who he
is? Does Jesus announce that he is the
Lord and he says, "Why are you
persecuting me?" Yes. Okay. Did the
spirit in the cave announce who it was?
It did. It did say it was a a spirit of
God. Um, it did. It can Can you Can you
All right. You know, I I have the hadith
actually. I have the hadith and we're
gonna re I'mma just kind It's kind of
long so I'm going just skim kind of
through it. Yeah. Yeah. I'm going show
on the screen and I want to I want you
to stop me when you see the part where
that spirit announces itself as a
messenger or angel of God. Okay? I want
you to stop me when you see that part.
So I'm going to pull up the hadith. Um
Sai Bukari 69. Man actually hold on. I
just actually had this yesterday or the
other. Was it yesterday? Yeah, it was
yesterday, man. We just read this
yesterday. And the only thing we do
around is we just read, man. Let's see
if I could go back to that reference. I
just had it in my phone. 6ix9ine. What?
What is it, guys? 69 Sukari. Man,
there's too much messages here. Okay.
Book13. Maybe it's I'm Sununa.com. So, I
go by these numbers. It's 69 something.
I just need a reminder of what that
hadith is. I'll just hit my people up.
They'll they'll send it to me real soon.
Me so pale. Let's see here. 6982. Okay.
Go ahead. Go ahead. 6982. There we go.
All right. Let's go ahead and share my
window here. Okay. So, it's pretty long
like I said, but here it is. Right.
Talks about how Muhammad would rece
would receive dreams.
Wait, what is the divine? Wait, it's
right there. I mean, what is that first
one? Scroll up a little bit more. It
says um the commencement of divine
inspiration to Allah's messenger. And I
I know that that you know this but
messengers are um in in the English the
anglicized uh angles. We don't got to do
all that. This is talking about Muhammad
and how he received revelation. So what
about remember what I'm asking for? Do
you remember what I'm asking for? You as
uh say it again. I'm asking for where
the spirit who visited Muhammad
announces who he is or announces that he
is from God. Okay. That's what I'm
looking for. All right. Okay. Well, he
doesn't he doesn't announce it here.
That's in um Yeah, that's in surah 2 uh
297. All right. What should I believe
here? Well, why should I believe
anything from the book of Acts? You
asked me the question. Well, this is the
point. I could give you a hundred things
about the book of Acts that are
believable. You can just go to my
channel. I have
like But this is this is the deflection.
This is the point. This is the point.
Clinton, you you're accusing Paul.
You're acc you're bringing accusations
against Paul and his revelation. Yet, if
you were to have the same the same
energy towards Islam, you would have to
reject. You have no reason to believe
his uh his experience in the danger.
Clinton, I need you to pay attention.
Clinton, pay attention. Okay. You
recognize that according to the history
of the prophets, Muhammad's experience
in the cave is nothing like what they've
experienced in the in historically,
right? Well, not nothing. It is unique.
So, it's nothing. It doesn't match the
historicity of how prophets received
revelation. Right. I said that one part
where well actually the two parts that
you mentioned that um he stayed in fear
and also at that moment the angel uh did
not say his name and the oppression the
physical oppression right well that's
staying in fear or that okay so so so
the the the peer the the adding unto his
fear physically attacking him physically
attacking him and and not announcing him
announcing that he's from God or who he
is completely, right? I No, I granted
the two of those aspects are, but the
attacking I I actually analogized to the
wrestling with Jacob. So I hold Hold on
a second. Does it say that the angel of
the Lord attacked attacked Jacob or does
it say that Jacob attacked the angel?
Meaning Jacob is the one who took hold
of the angel while the angel was trying
to get him off. Well, they wrestled and
then the angel would actually not. What
was the source of the wrestling? Was it
that the angel came and attacked Jacob
or was it that Jacob grabbed hold of the
angel when the angel was about to leave?
Right. So,
okay. Yeah. All right. So, it wasn't
that the angel attacked Jacob like we
see this spirit attacks Muhammad. Right.
So, it's a little different. Yes. No,
that's not a little different. It's
completely different. We have one we
have the angel being attacked by Jacob.
We have the angel being attacked by
Jacob. We have the spirit uh Muhammad
being attacked by this spirit.
completely different but they are
wrestling each other. No. Do you see any
wrestling going on here in the cave?
Nobody wrestling this spirit or is he
getting dog walk but he did not over
Jacob found that he could not overcome
the angel. Clinton why why do you have
an empty tomb for I'm kind of confused.
Well, why is your why is your that has
something to do about um Paul's belief
in the empty tomb if it is empty or not.
But that's a that's a side question. Uh
I want to I okay so logic I I will grant
you your points. We differ a little bit
on maybe the edges but I do grant that
Muhammad's visitation uh is unique and
that's also because Muhammad it doesn't
match historically. It doesn't match
historically. So therefore you should
reject Muhammad. Well I don't know if it
m I don't see I wouldn't say it doesn't
when I when I say that Paul isn't
matching historically. I mean that
everything that Paul says is not just
unique. It contradicts what we know
about history. For example,
that that's what this is what this is
why I brought you to this. I'm seeing if
you're going to be consistent. When we
know the history of the prophets, do we
know them to be attacked by a spirit to
get revelation? But no, thank you. So
therefore, reject Muhammad because he
was attacked by a spirit to receive his
revelation. So therefore, it contradicts
the history of revelation. Can we Okay.
So, so I wouldn't do that because each
of the prophets have Because you're a
Muslim. Well, hold on.
Each of the prophets have uh No, God
think you're funny. Each of the each of
the prophets have different unique
encounters with Do any of Do any of
their encounters contradict the others?
Well, I don't think I don't think
Muhammad's encounters How's that
contradicting? Because it's unique.
Okay. So I I understand that you're
trying to frame it as unique. It's not
unique. If you don't say it again, when
you have prophets, they never think that
they're demonpossessed after an
experience with God. Do they? I cannot
think of someone thinking that they were
possessed by the demon. The answer is
no. How about suicidal? Or suicidal? Are
any of the prophets ever suicidal after
an experience with God? Um, no. No.
Nope. So we see Muhammad is suicidal
after his experience in the cave and he
is oppressed in his experience in the
cave. So these this experience
contradicts the historicity of
revelation with the prophets. Right. I
would not phrase that that way but I
understand. Well, again, I would just
say that uh Okay, hold on, hold on, hold
on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Let's say
if Paul, if Paul, if this was Paul,
switch roles.
Suicidal after seeing the risen Jesus
after Hey, no. After seeing this light,
this supposed light a light in a cave.
If this was Paul, you would be blasting
this from the top of every min. No, no,
no, no, no. Because my problem with
Paul, I was just making the comparison
that there's a little oppression and
fear going on there. My problem with
Paul isn't that he the the apparition on
the road to the massochist. My problem
is that everything Shut up. Well, no.
Okay. The problem is everything around
that, right? So, when he goes to the
high priest and stop I I have to stop
you here, Clinton, because now you're
being dishonest. Well, not now. I mean,
but you're continuously being dishonest,
man. I think the first thing you brought
up for your problem with Paul was the
apparation uh on his way to Damascus.
That's the first thing you said. Well,
okay. Yes. So, I do that is problematic.
But the reason why the reason why it's
problematic, it's not problematic on its
own, right?
Well, that's that would be if it was
then I would be actually a hypocrite,
right? You know what? Say say that
again. If the apparition of Jesus on the
road to Damasochus was problematic
alone, then I would be a hypocrite. But
that's not my argument. Got it. Okay,
you guys cut me off. Um, I don't believe
in his apparition, but the reason why I
don't believe in his apparition is
because all the context clues around it
don't make sense. For example, when Paul
goes to Caiaphas and Anifice, the high
priest, this is already a mitchmatch. We
are told by Paul that he's a Pharisee of
Pharisees. Well, why would a Pharisee a
Pharisees be working for the high priest
who's a Sadducee to Sadducees and the
Pharisees and the Sadducees are
essentially at war? That's That's not
hard. That's not hard. Okay, that's not
hard at all. Like, that's not hard. Why
would Why would a uh a Spurs fan and a
Golden State fan root against the Lakers
if they were in the playoffs? That's not
even a comp that's not even a
compromise. I'm just saying like common
an enemy of an enemy is my friend. They
would be more than happy to do that. And
the high and the high priest did
irregular things all the time. They did
irregular things with the trial with
Jesus. And the way they did that, that's
not that weird. You're doing a priority
history. You're deciding in advance what
would or would not happen based on your
own like ideas. Well, the Pharisees
literally kill the Pharisees literally
kill uh Anifice. So, I don't it's not
just they wouldn't work with him. He
they end up later killing. What does
that have to What does that have to do
with them having a a combined goal to
get rid of this Jesus I'm sorry. Say
that one more time. What does that have
to do with them having a combined goal
to get rid of this Jesus narrative and
this explosion? Well, again, so he goes
to the high priest um to get letters to
go to Damasochus to persecute
Christians. There's nothing about that
that is historical. There's no evidence.
No, no, no. You've decided, Clinton,
you've decided in advance that that
can't be historical. But history is not
like that. You don't think No, no, no,
no. Hold on. Hold up. Hold up. Hold up.
Yeah. Well, of course there's not an
external thing. A lot So many different
historical records that we have are from
a single source. If we just threw out
everything if we threw out everything
that we thought doesn't quite jive and
if we threw out everything that um we
just decided in advance is unlikely,
then we wouldn't know a whole lot about
unlikely. There's literally not a single
reference in all of the historical text
that we have of the functional Sanhedrin
in Jerusalem of an extra regional
extradition especially under the Roman
occupation. What does that got to do
with anything? But Clinton, you're
you're arguing you're arguing from
you're arguing from silence. Okay. And
you are you aware of all the other like
arguments for the reliability of the
book of Acts? Do you know anything about
that or are you just finding like one
thing that you can decide in advance is
just too unlikely to happen? Let's use
let's use this man's logic. Do do we
have anything do we have anything in in
in in Egypt or Egyptologist? Do we have
anything in their sources or history,
Eric, that mention crucifixion? We do
not. So why in the world is the Quran
having Pharaoh talk about people being
crucified? Well, actually historically,
um,
people because remember Rome, uh,
overtook parts of Egypt. And so I guess
what does that got to do with what does
that got to do with Pharaoh way before
Rome mentioning crucifixion? Well,
crucifixions although they would come to
be known as a uniquely Roman execution,
they actually started well before the do
you have do you have any evidence within
Egypt and their sources that they were
performing crucifixions? Not in Egypt,
but in North Africa. Oh, so you don't
have you have nothing in Egypt claiming
that the pharaohs were performing or
ordering crucifixions. Yet you have
Muhammad talking about that the pharaoh
was issuing out
crucifixions when historically we have
no accounts of that even existing at
that time. So Muhammad must be a false
prophet, right? Do you know that we
don't have or do you just simply not
know? Because I don't know. I don't
know. I know
that in
Sanhedrin's saying that there's nothing.
We
we know that the Persians are the ones
that came up. I'm going to follow up
with an email. I'm going to follow up an
email with this one. Uh because because
this is different. I I'm willing to say
I don't
Well, in the sense that I'm willing to
say that I don't know that if in the
Egyptian case um if there were
specifically Roman style crucifixions
happening during the time of of of
Pharaoh that and when you find that
there wasn't then Muhammad's a false
prophet for being anti-historical,
right? It will definitely deal um a
blow. Uh no, no doubts. No doubts.
You're a capper. Get the heck out of my
house. That's right. I'm a what? I'm I'm
just I'm just ripping off the sneak
difference though. I actually studied
the Jerusalem Sanhedrin. There's not
this is there's not a single record but
again you're doing our priority history.
I've actually studied the the history of
the testify. Let me sit here. Um but in
the first what's happening in the first
century is there's a lot of different
Jewish heresies. And so did you study
the Quran? Did you study the Quran like
you studied the Sanhedrin in the Well,
the the Sanhedrin is a uh Well, to me
it's not, you know, but yes, I've
studied the Quran. Uh but the point is
on the So, the same way that you studied
So, the same way that you studied these
sources, you studied the Quran the same
way and found that it is
anti-historical, right? Logic. Um I like
I said, I think that your point about
the crucifixion needs to be looked into
further. Doesn't need to be looked into
further. It there's nothing that exists.
I need to prove it for myself because
you you haven't cited any historical
references. You haven't cited any
neither have you. You're just arguing
from cited the Sanhedrin record
regarding what about extraditions. There
are no extra regional extradition of
Jews to the Jerusalem Sanhedrin from
around according to what are you saying
that there's not any are you saying that
are you saying that there's a negation
of this or you're just saying that we
don't have a record of that? We have the
record of the Sanhedrin and its trials.
That's not what I asked. I asked, "Do
are you saying that you have records
negating a joint, you know, um, a joint
decision to go?" That's a ridiculous
question. You're asking me to prove a
negative. You're asking me to prove a
negative. That's intellectually
dishonored. No, I'm not asking you to
prove. You're saying that this is a
negative. This act says it's a positive.
You're saying, "No, this couldn't have
happened because we don't have a record
of a joint uh, you know, extra regional
um, joint mission, whatever." No, you're
asking me. No, no, no. The reason why
the way that you're asking me the
question is inevitable. You're asking
me, do I have documentation that
explain? This is what I'm asking. This
is what I'm asking. Are you saying that
your the sources that you're reading
negate a joint regional, you know,
whatever you said? Now that you put it
that way, yes, because in Roman sources,
it is the Romans who have the political
authority. And that's But where does
Wait, hold on. Hold on a hold on a
second. who has the authority over the
Jew the Jewish uh Jewish diction and
their laws and their customs is how they
punish each other. Specifically the
religious um Thank you. Thank you.
Exactly. So Rome left that up to the
religious leaders to deal with their own
people when it came to their religious
customs and their laws. Right. Whereas
it crossed into Roman's jurisdiction
which this had nothing to do with Roman
this had nothing to do with Roman
jurisdiction because Jerusalem the
Jerusalem Sanhedrin doesn't have any
authority over the Jews in Damascus.
Damascus is in a totally different
providence. It's not even part of
Israel. Hold on. What is your evidence
of this? You don't know that Damasochus
is not part of Israel? No, no, no. What
I'm asking is what is your evidence that
they don't follow the the orders of the
high priest? The high priest? Who
doesn't follow the the Romans? The Jews
in Damascus not following the orders of
the high priest, the religious leaders
or the Sanhedrin or the Pharisees? Well,
I don't know what you mean by orders.
We're talking about extradition. Dude,
you just said you just said that the the
Jews in Damascus are not under the
authority of the high priest in
Jerusalem. That's what you said. Yeah,
that's exactly true. What what what is
your evidence of this? That's not that
there's first of all, each of the um
outside communities in diaspora in
Judaism had at this time local or small
Sanhedrin that dealt with their local
issues. I'm talking about the high
priest. What is your evidence that they
did not take that they were not under
the orders of the high priest? How many
how many high priests were there at the
time that we're talking? We're talking
about Anifice and Caiaphas. So, how many
high priests were there? Well, those
two. And then we're talking about the
Sanhedrin, which is a court of 72. And
they're the high priest over who?
They're the high priest over Jerusalem.
Over just Jerusalem. And more
specifically, they're the temple
administration. Oh, are they only the
are they the high priest of the Jews
only in Jerusalem? Well, actually, now
that you're asking, we do have
extradition record that they were able
to extradite people in and around
Jerusalem, which is still very much well
in Israel. So, yes, they're over Israel
and they're over uh they're over Israel.
So, even the Jews in Damascus are under
them. No, they're over the state of
Israel, the nation state of Israel, not
the people, not the Jewish people in
France. Nice. So, it looks like it looks
It looks like um you know, I mean, we
can go in circles on this all day.
You're going to beat my head open with
this. Yeah. Yeah. But I I'm I'm done
beating it up. It looks like uh the the
reasons why you reject Paul are the
reasons why you should reject Muhammad.
That's what it looks like to me. Well,
like I told you that on the crucifixion
issue, I will definitely uh if I can,
I'll follow back up with an email and if
I'm wrong, I can admit that. But I what
I'm interested in here is why you can't
admit that this entire story we just we
just we just refuted everything you just
tried to say argument is weak. You
didn't refute it. You just you your
argument is weak. Clinton, I have an
hourlong video on the reliability of the
book of Acts. My friend David Palman has
an hourlong video on the reliability of
the book of Acts. You can read uh Colin
Heammer, the book of Acts in the setting
of Henistic History. You can read
William Paley uh Jay Paul and I you can
read those. I have a thousand different
scholars you can read on the book of
Acts too and in a lot of Yeah. And I
will I will I would go up against any of
those scholars opinions. I would put any
of the people that I just named. Okay.
Well, I just up against them until you
can read
Clinton. Clinton Clinton until you can
read and articulate the positive side
for the book of Acts and put it in a
steel man position then I
just I didn't finish. Why are you
jumping in? Okay. then I don't I don't I
don't want to hear it until you can
steal man the position for the
reliability of the book of Acts and
actually look into it yourself and I'm
telling you this is gonna be rewarding
reading for you. Well, I do think then
then then then you don't have a you
don't have a leg to stand on when it
comes to criticizing it. I've heard all
this stuff. Well, I think for
example doesn't really you changed you
came on and you changed the topic. So if
Paul put himself and said, "Hey guys,
I'm I'm the apostle to the Gentiles
according to Hosea chapter 17," that
would obviously be a huge red flag. And
so we've already seen historically you
said that things don't line. We've
already said that there's a difference
in the experiences with the prophets.
Well, this is another thing that no true
prophet would ever do. And so that's
that's that's two that's two things. And
so look into the crucifixion thing. look
into the materials that I'm recommending
you on the book of Acts. At least jump
onto my buddy David's video on on the
book of Acts. Well, I haven't and tell
me, email me where he's wrong. That
that's what I The book of Acts is the
longest book in the New Testament. I'm
only talking about one well, actually
two specific parts. So, there's a lot in
the book of Acts I think is credible.
For example, um although the book of
Hebrews will say that Jesus is the final
and ultimate sacrifice, we'll see in the
book of Acts that the disciples continue
to bring sacrifices in accordance with
the law of Moses up until the time that
the the temple is destroyed. And I think
that's probably very reliable history.
Thanks. So the parts that disagree with
our theology is the parts that you're
going to be like, "Oh, that's probably
good." Okay. Well, not I mean, not
necessarily. I agree. I'm gonna go ahead
and bring up the next person, man. Thank
you guys. Yep. Good talking to you.